[Music]
welcome to now you see it when
characters drown in movies they're gone
forever
but more than just the character leaves
they always take something with them
maybe they take away fear a friendship
trust in others or a desire to go
somewhere new but what happens when a
character starts drowning and survives
he's not gone forever but instead he's
alive but he isn't just alive he's alive
all over again he's supposed to be dead
when he it rises up again he changes but
change isn't the right word it's more
violent than change he's reborn let's
look at drowning more symbolically in
The Truman Show Truman lives on an
island caged from reality
he's been conditioned to through the
outside world after the drowning of his
father finally he sails out of his world
and confronts the next nearly drowning
in the process it's the same pattern we
see in baptism death and rebirth through
the medium of water
Truman goes in still scared of the
outside world and comes out ready he
died and was born again in any drowning
scene we see symbolic rebirth which
originates from the judeo-christian
sacrament of baptism a new believer is
taking completely underwater dies out of
his old self and is reborn in his
identity as a follower of Christ what
are you talking about we got bigger fish
to fry using water as death and rebirth
imagery has been used for centuries in
literature but it has since found its
way into film every drowning experience
has a different meaning based on the
context whoever causes you to nearly
drown is the symbolic enemy and whoever
saves you is your symbolic Savior this
includes drowning yourself and saving
yourself and if you're unable to save
someone else that represents losing a
part of yourself if that person was
close to you baptism imagery is not
restricted to violent drowning we can
see the same death and rebirth more
subtly in say a shower scene or a sewage
drain followed via torrent
down port while not as apparent any
scene where a character gets cleansed
with water can represent a death and
rebirth to the character the shower
scene in psycho has baptism imagery
actress Janet Leigh said in her book on
the film Marian had decided to go back
to Phoenix come clean and take the
consequence so when she stepped into the
bathtub It was as if she were stepping
into the baptismal waters the spray
beating down on her was purifying the
corruption from her mind purging the
evil from her soul she was like a virgin
again tranquil at peace in the shower
she's cleansing herself of her sins in
her attempt though she gets murdered and
fails in her baptism countless films use
water as a way of showing a deep
internal change for a character so
whenever someone goes underwater whether
they're hiding feeling trapped getting
superpowers or falling out of an
exploding plane remember that getting
dunked underwater represents a part of
them dying and another part being reborn
or maybe it's just a way to get a kiss
from Wendy peppercorn